hepiniz önce kanalına Hoşgeldiniz
gençler 9 sınıf edebiyat ders çalışmamız
devam ediyor Bu videoda şiir ötesini ele
alacağız yani tek bir videoda şiir
ünitesini bitireceğiz arkadaşlar hem
sınav öncesinde hızlı bir tekrar yapmış
olacaksınız hem de bu üniteyi tek bir
seferde öğrenmek istiyorsanız bu video
sizler için mükemmel olacak peki bu
videoda hangi konular var şöyle bir konu
listemizde göz atalım Öncelikle
Arkadaşlar sizlere Nazım birimi nazım
biçimi ve Nazım türünden bahsedeceğim bu
kavramlar Önemli çünkü 10 11
12 yine bu kavramlar karşımıza çıkacak
Hatta AYT edebiyatta Yani önemli Daha
sonrasında ayet unsurlarına bakacağız
burada arkadaşlar ölçüyü öğreneceğiz
redifi öğreneceğiz kafi öğreneceğiz ve
kafiye şemasını öğreneceğiz ki temel
konulardır bundan sonra da konularına
göre şiir türlerine göz atacağız imgeyi
öğreneceğiz edebi sanatlar son derece
önemli ve dil bilgisi olarak da sıfat
konusunu Bu videoda sizlere aktaracağım
yani dopdolu bir video sizleri bekliyor
çok heyecanlıyım Çünkü güzel bir çalışma
olacak Bunu şimdiden hissedebiliyorum
derse başlamadan önce de ufak bir
hatırlatma Emek harcayarak bu videoları
sizlerle paylaşıyorum Sizler de bu
videoyu beğenerek kanalıma abone olarak
bana destekte bulunabilirsiniz ve hiç
vakit kaybetmeden dersimize başlayalım
arkadaşlar yorulacağız uzun bir video
olabilir ama gereksiz yerlere çıkardım
sadece en önemli noktaları hızlı bir
şekilde sizlere aktaracağım sıkılmayın
arkadaşlar unutmayın güzel bir gelecek
için sabırla bıkmadan çalışmalısınız
diyorum ve şiir nedir şöyle bir şiire
Giriş yaparak dersimize başlayalım
seslerin uyumlu kullanımı resimli ve
zengin imgillere dayanan yani zengin bir
anlama sahip olan edebi metinlere Biz
şiir diyoruz arkadaşlar şiirin
edebiyattaki bir diğer adı da coşku ve
heyecanı dile getiren metinlerdir Coşku
verir ve insanı heyecanlandırır şiirler
şiirler insan duygusuna seslenir Coşku
uyandırır zengin bir düş gücü Barındırır
ahenk ve etkileyicilik tabii ki şiirde
ön plana çıkar ve arkadaşlar şiir yazan
yani duygularını etkili bir şekilde dile
getiren kişi ise biz ne deriz Şair
ederiz şiirde yine arkadaşlar temel
anlamda ifade edilen soyut olan genel
olan kavrama Biz tema deriz TEMA'nın
sınırlandırılmış yani özele indirgenmiş
haline ise konu denilmektedir yani aşkı
anlatıyorsam şiirde bu temadır ama Kimin
aşkı bu Ahmet'le Ayşe dersem İşte bu da
konu olur diyorum ve geliyoruz mahlas ve
tapşırmak kavramlarına arkadaşlar bizim
edebiyatımız iki gelenek haline devam
etmiştir 100 Yıllar Boyunca
bir halk edebiyatı 2 Divan Edebiyatı
Divan edebiyatına şairlerinin kendi
takma adlarını kullanmasına Biz mahlas
deriz halk edebiyatında ise şairlerin
takma ad kullanmasına ise tapşırma denir
mesela şu beyte Bakın arkadaşlar burada
Baki ismi geçmektedir Baki şairimizin
kullanmış olduğu bir mahlastır yani
takma addır Divan edebiyatına ait olduğu
için Buna marlas diyoruz ancak
Karacaoğlan halk edebiyatında kullanılan
bir lakap olduğu için ona da tapşırma
diyoruz Şimdi arkadaşlar nazım birimine
geldik Bakın bu önemli Nazım birimi
nedir Arkadaşlar Nazım birimi bir şiirin
içindeki en küçük parçadır o parçayı ise
dizedir arkadaşlar yani şiirdeki her
satıra Biz ne deriz bize bak hoşça bak
zatına ki züppe-i Alemsin Sen demişim
tek bir satır Buna ne denir Mısra ya da
Dize denir iki tane alt alta Dize
sıralarsam ne olur Arkadaşlar bunun adı
beyit olur Burada gördüğünüz gibi
Fuzuli'nin Son derece güzel bir beyti
var beni
Cefadan ya ruhsal maz mı felekler yandı
ahımdan muradım şeyimi Yanmaz mı diyorum
ve geliyoruz dörtlü arkadaşlar 4 tane
dizi alt alta sıralarsanız bunun adı da
ne olur dörtlük olur Bakın bir iki üç
dört tane Dize var bunun dışında
kalanlar ise arkadaşlar bendir yani 3 5
6 7 8 dizeyi alt alta getirirseniz buna
genel anlamda bentlenir kafanızı
karıştırmak istemiyorum ama divan
edebiyatında dörtlüklere de yine
bentlenir ama bunu silebilirsiniz
Kafanız karışmasın Burada da Arkadaşlar
bir üçlük var bakın bir iki üç dizi alt
alta gelmiş Dolayısıyla bu beyit olmaz
bu dörtlük olmaz bu dizi olmaz Ne olur
bu Bent olur arkadaşlar Türk
edebiyatında bir çok Nazım birimi
kullanılmıştır mesela İslamiyet öncesi
Türk edebiyatına ve halk edebiyatına
genel anlamda dörtlükler kullanmıştır
ancak Divan edebiyatına ise beyit ve
onun dışında ben kullanmıştır yani halk
edebiyatı denildiği zaman hemen
aklınızda dörtlük gelmeli Osmanlı
edebiyatı denildiği zaman da hemen
aklınıza beyit gelmeli Bunu unutma
karşına çıkacaktır diyorum ve Nazım
biçimine geldik şiirin nazım birimi
ölçüsü uyak örgüsüne göre kazanmış oldu
biçimsel özelliklere Biz nazım biçimi ya
da bir diğer adıyla nazım şekli diyoruz
Dolayısıyla nazım şekli ile karşınıza
gelirse sakın ha Kafanız karışmasın ve
yine adından da anlıyoruz ki arkadaşlar
nazım biçimi şiirin şekilsel
özellikleriyle ilgilidir ve Şurada da
ifade ettiğimiz gibi onlarca asıllık bir
Türk edebiyatından bahsetmekteyiz
arkadaşlar yani İslamiyet öncesine kadar
gider yani binli yıllar öncesine kadar
giden bir edebiyattır Türk edebiyatı
Dolayısıyla bu kadar uzun bir edebiyat
içerisinde onlarca farklı nazım biçimi
kullanılmıştır birazdan ona tablo
halinde göz atacağız ama arkadaşlar
unutmayın nazım biçimi bir şiire neye
göre verilir o şiirin uyak örgüsüne
ölçüsüne ve nazım birimine göre verilir
şimdi bir tablo halinde Nazım
biçimlerine göz atalım bizim ed
etrafımızda kullanılan Öncelikle halk
edebiyatına bakalım halk edebiyatı kendi
içerisinde Aşık tarzı halk edebiyatı
anonim halk edebiyatı ve Dini Tasavvuf
halk edebiyatı olarak üçe ayrılır şimdi
Anonim halk edebiyatındaki Nazım
biçimlerini göz atalım burada mani ve
türkü vardır arkadaşlar yani manene
denildiği zaman hemen aklımıza tek bir
dörtlük gelecek bakın Nazım birimi kahve
şeması a a x a olacak ve 7'li ölçü
kullanılacak yani
Ece ölçüsü işte Arkadaşlar şu şekilsel
özellikleri Biz nazım biçimi diyoruz
halk edebiyatının ikinci bir kolu olan
Aşık tarzı halk edebiyatında da koşma
semai varsa destan gibi nazım biçimleri
vardır Bunları daha sonraki yıllarda
yani 10 11 ve 12 sınıfta göreceksiniz
Şimdi bir de Divan edebiyatına bakalım
Divan edebiyatında da beyitlerle kurulan
nazım biçimleri gazel kaside Mesnevi
kıta sattır bentlerle kurulanlar ise
tuyu Murabba şarkı muames derginden ve
tercüment'te mesela gazele bakalım gazel
denildiği zaman Arkadaşlar şu şekilde
beyitler gelir aklımıza en az 5 beyitin
olması lazım kahve şeması a a b a c a d
a diye gitmesi lazım ve hangi ölçü
kullanacak aruz ölçüsü kullanacak bakın
bunun şekliyle bu manevi şekli
birbirinden farklı buna ne diyoruz nazım
biçimi diyoruz ve batı etkisine geçen
Türk edebiyatına yani 19 yüzyıldan sonra
batıdan aldığımız yeni nazım biçimleri
vardır onlar da sone terzilerin mat Trio
ile Balat ve serbest nazımdır Bunlar 11
ve 12 sınıfın konusu olacak ama şu
tabloyu unutmuyoruz arkadaşlar Aşina
olun Bu size katkı sunacaktır diyorum ve
şimdi Nazım türüne bakalım Nazım biçim
neydi şiirinin şekilsel özellikleriyle
aldığı isimdi Nazım türü ise arkadaşlar
şiirin konu ve temasına göre aldığı
isimdir arasındaki fark budur arkadaşlar
şimdi bir de Nazım bir türüne bakalım
yine bir tablo geldi karşımıza İslamiyet
öncesinde Sago vardır koşuk vardır
destan vardır arkadaşlar Sabun nedir
ölüm temalı şiirlerdir Koşuk nedir Aşk
Doğa kahramanlık temalı şeylerdir Bakın
bu sefer de temasına göre bir
gruplandırma yaptım buna Nazım türü
denir gelelim halk edebiyatına halk
edebiyatında güzelleme Vardır koçaklama
vardır taşlama vardır ağıt vardır yani
bir ölüyü anlatıyorsanız bu ağıttır
savaştan bahsediyorsanız bakın konu
olarak koçaklama aşktan bahsediyorsanız
güzelleme birini eleştiriyorsanız halk
edebiyatına Bu da taşlama olur Bakın
konusuna göre isim veriyorum işte tekrar
söylüyorum bu Nazım türüdür dini tasva
halk edebiyatına ilahi nefes deme Nutuk
Şadiye devriye vardır anonim
aktüeliyatına yine ninni ve ağıt
karşımıza çıkar Divan edebiyatında ise
konusuna göre şiirler şu şekilde
Arkadaşlar bu önemli çünkü AYT
edebiyatta buradan her sene bir tane
soru gelmekte mesela 2022'de müracaat
geldi yani Allah'a yalvarış Bey'e
karışan oldu şiirlere Divan edebiyatına
münacaat denir bunu ÖSYM sormuştu son
derece de basit Allah'ın birliğini
yüceliğini anlatırsan bu tevhiddir Hz
Peygamber'e övgü dizersem bu ne haktır
birinin ölümünden bahsediyorsan bu Divan
edebiyatında mersiyedir birini
seviyorsan bu divan edebiyatının
methedir birini eleştiriyorsan bu Divan
edebiyatında hiçbir yere şairi kendisine
veriyorsa buna Fahriye denir arkadaşlar
İşte gördüğünüz gibi konusuna göre isim
alıyoruz Buna da Nazım türü diyoruz
Dolayısıyla Nazım birimi nazım biçimi ve
Nazım türünü gördük oldukça basit
Bunları hiçbir zaman unutmuyoruz diyorum
ve şimdi geldik arkadaşlar hece ölçüsüne
milli ölçümüzdür arkadaşlar hece ölçüsü
ve Hece ölçüsünün temelinde şu vardır
hece sayılarının eşit olması arkadaşlar
hece ölçüsü bu ve aynı zamanda şiir
okunurken Bazı yerlerde durulur bu
yerlere hece ölçüsünde Durak adı verilir
arkadaşlar ve bu duraklar kesinlikle
kelimeyi ortadan bölmemeli iki kelime
ortasına gelmeli hece ölçüsü özetle bu
kadar ancak biz detaylı bir şekilde
bakmaya devam ediyoruz 7 8 ve 11 ile
hece ölçüsü en çok kullanılan
kalıplardır ve önemli bir bilgi
İslamiyetin kabulünden önceki
edebiyatımıza da yine hece ölçüsü
kullanılmıştır yani binlerce yıllık bir
geleneğimizdir hece ölçüsü İslamiyetin
kabul edilmesinden sonra ise halk
edebiyatında yüzlerce kullanılmış millet
edebiyatta da yine hece ölçüsü ön plana
çıkmışlar arkadaşlar burada da hece
sayısına göre Durak görüyoruz yani
arkadaşlar Mesela bir şiir 7 heceden
oluşuyorsa bunu Biz büyük bir ihtimalle
4+3 diyebiliriz Eğer 8 heceden
oluşuyorsa bunu 4 artı 4 şeklinde
böleriz ve burada arkadaşlar birçok hece
sayısını görmekteyiz ama en çok
kullanılan neydi
7-8-11 ve 14'lü ölçüyü de bunları
kırmızıyla gösterdim şimdi Bir örnek
üzerinden ne demek istediğimi
somutlaştıralım Bakın arkadaşlar
okumaktan Murat ne kişi hakkında
bilmekte şimdi ne yapıyoruz hece
sayısını buluyoruz 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 hece
var hocam kısayol yok mu bunun var
arkadaşlar ünlü harfleri sayarsanız
eşittir hece sayısıdır Dolayısıyla hece
sayısında bulmuş olursunuz 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
bulduk arkadaşlar 7 heceden oluşuyor 7
heceden oluşuyorsanız bölerdik 4+3
şeklinde böyle artık bakalım 1 2 3 4
buraya geldi buraya buraya ve şuraya
arkadaşlar yani Bu Şiir okurken
okumaktan Murat ne kişi Hakkı bilmektir
okudun bilmezsin Habir kuru emektir
şekli okumamız lazım yani Arkadaşlar şu
duraklarda durmamız lazım
4+3=7'li hece ölçüsü hece ölçüsü bu
kadar diyorum ve geldik şimdi kahve
yaşamasını arkadaşlar Dize sonlarında
kafilelerin diziliş özelliklerine göre
gruplandırılmasına biz kahve şeması ya
da kahve düzeni ya da uyak örgüsü
diyoruz 3 farklı ismi var karşınıza
Bunlardan biri çıkarsa sakına şaşırmayın
hepsi aynı şey kahve yaşaması
belirlenirken Biz ortak dizeleri aynı
harfte gösteririz mesela a a b b
şeklinde Ve unutmayın kafe yaşaması
şiirde Ahengi sağlamak için kullanılan
unsurlardan bir tanesidir nazım biçimi
neye göre belirlenirdi ölçü Nazım birimi
ve kahve yaşamasına göre Dolayısıyla
önemli Türkiye'de edebiyatında 5 farklı
kahve şeması vardı düz kafeye çapraz
kafeye sarmal kafiye mani tipi kafe ve
örüşü kahve şimdi bunları hızlıca
görelim arkadaşlar düz kahpeden
başlayalım Eğer bir dörtlük a a b
şeklinde sıralanmışsa buna düz kafeye
denir bakalım arkadaşlar halinden de
bitmiş buna a diyeceğim elinden halinden
benziyor mu benziyor Kafe olarak buna
daha diyeceğim belinden benziyor
arkadaşlar buna daha diyeceğim zamandır
benziyor mu Hayır o zaman ben buna B diy
diyeceğim harflerin bir önemi yok
arkadaşlar buna y y z de diyebilirdim
Önemli olan şuydu arkadaşlar ortak
seslere sahip olan ilk 3 dizeyi aynı
seslerle gösterebilmek bu kadar
geliyoruz şimdi çapraz kafeye arkadaşlar
Eğer kahve aşaması şu şekilde olursa
Anadolu'da a tanı B yolunda a çobanı B
Bakın şu ikisi birbirine benziyor
dolayısıyla nasıl bir kahve yaşaması var
çapraz var arkadaşlar çaprazlama gelmiş
buna Bu nedenle çapraz kavga ediyoruz
bir de sarmal kafe vardır yani
arkadaşlar a b b a şeklinde olursa bakın
ortadakiler bunlar şunlar da ortak
sesler Dolayısıyla ne yapmış oldu a B'yi
sarmış oldu bu nedenle Buna da sarmal
kafe diyoruz Bir de manita vardır
arkadaşlar O da Aaa x şeklinde
kafiyelidir yani 1 2 ve 4 dizi aynı
kafede olacak üçüncüsü farklı olacak
buna da mani tipi uyak denir ve
arkadaşlar Batı etkisine geçen Türk
edebiyatına yeni bir kahve yaşaması
ortaya çıkmıştır Bu da öışık Kafiye
dikkat edin arkadaşlar üçlükler halinde
ilerler ilk bize a diyeceğiz ikinci zp
diyeceğiz ve üçüncüsüne yine a diyeceğiz
sonra arkadaşlar ortadaki yani Farklı
olan bir sonraki bendin ilk dizisini
oluşturacak bakın b b şeklinde ortadaki
Yine farklı olacak ortadaki sonra ki
bendin ilk dizesini oluşturacak bu
şekilde örülüşü ilerleyen kafe aşamasına
Biz diyoruz 5 farklı K5 şeması
vardı düz kafi sarmal kafiye çapraz
kafeye mani tipi uya hiçbir zaman
unutmuyoruz dedim ve Şimdi redife geldi
Bakın arkadaşlar önemli noktalardan bir
tanesine geldim Redif ve kafi Bundan
sonrasını daha dikkatli dinle ve sakına
sıkılma tamam mı sıkılma arkadaşım Neden
başarılı olmak istiyorsan Arkadaşım çok
çalışman gerekiyor
sıkılmaman gerekiyor dinlenmek gibi bir
şey bizler için yok arkadaşlar
yorulacağız çalışacağız terleyeceğiz ve
emin olun en sonunda başarılı olan
Öyleyse şimdi redife bakalım Dize
sonlarında tekrarlanan aynı harflerden
oluşan bak Altını çiziyorum aynı görev
ve anlamdaki ekler ya da kelime ya da
kelime gruplarına Biz redif diyoruz yani
Dize sonunda aynı anlamda iki kelimeler
Tekrar ederse buna reddediyoruz bu bir
iki aynı görevdeki ekler Tekrar ederse
Bu da dedidir yani redditler ek haliniz
olabilir kelime halinde de olabilir Bunu
unutma yine önemli bir nokta şiir de
ahenk unsurları incelenirken Dize
sonunda Öncelikle redifi aramalıyız
arkadaşlar redifi arayacaksın redifi
buldun ya da bulamadın Ondan sonra
kafeye geçeceksin birinci önceliğimiz
redif hemen Şuraya bir yazayım ve tekrar
edelim redditler ek ve kelime halinde
bulunabilir bir örnek hemen bakalım
bulalım birlikte
kardeşin telaşın gözyaşın beni şekli
biten bir dörtlük var Recep nerede
aranırdı Daha doğrusu aye unsurları
dizenin sonunda bakıyoruz arkadaşlar
kardeşin telaşın gözyaşın Bunlar
benziyor dördü Boş verin benzemediği
için kafamızı bu karıştırmasın şifremi
değiştirelim arkadaşlar kardeşin telaşın
gözyaşın derken Sizce burada aynı
kelimeler tekrar etmiş mi Hayır yani
kelime halinde redif yok Peki ek halinde
redif var mı var arkadaşlar bakın kardaş
kelimesi telaş kelimesi ve yaş kelimesi
bunların sonuna -ın gelmiş ın gelmiş
ın gelmiş arkadaşlar yani iyelik eki
ortak sesler mi Evet ortak sesler ve
ekler Dolayısıyla ben buna redif diyorum
arkadaşlar
kafeyi aramamız gerekiyor ama onu
birazdan arayacağız bir örnek daha
verelim dermana muhtaç kurbana muhtaç
fermana muhtaç ve kaç gündür şeklinde
biten bir dörtlük var sonuncusu
benzemiyor bunu silelim kafamız
karışmasın Bakın arkadaşlar muhtaç
muhtaç muhtaç aynı kelimeler aynı anlama
gelen kelimeler tekrar etmiş biri size
sonunda etmiş ben buna redif derim bitti
mi Hayır arkadaşlar benzerlik kaybolana
kadar ben bakmaya devam edeceğim şimdi
muhtacın soluna döndüm Derman kurban ve
Ferman sözcüklerine Aa yönelme hal
ekleri gelmiş mi gelmiş arkadaşlar
Bunlar ortak ekler mi Evet o zaman A
yine burada redif olacak Bitti mi Hayır
geriye Derman kurban Ferman kaldı Bakın
arkadaşlar Ağın Ağın ortak sesler
dolayısıyla bir ve iki iki Ses
benzerliği varsa buna tam kafi diyoruz
Dolayısıyla gördüğünüz gibi oldukça
basit unutma ek ve aynı anlamdaki kelime
tekrarı redifti gerisi kafeydi şimdi
kafeye gelelim şiirde 2 ya da daha çok
dizi arasında farklı anlam ve görevdeki
seslerin kelimelerin benzerliğine Biz
kafiye diyoruz arkadaşlar Eğer bir ses
benziyorsa buna yarım kafiye iki ses
benzer sabuna tam kafi 3 ses benziyorsa
buna zengin kafe denir ama bunun dışında
Tunç Kafiye ve cinas kafiye var Şimdi
onları da göz atacağız ama Öncesinde bir
örnek Yunus'un sözlüğü gözlüğü gözü
Aşkın Elinden bu benzemiyor bunu sildik
Arkadaşlar şimdi şuralara bakalım söz
sözcüğüne ü gelmiş göz sözcüğüne üye
gelmiş öze
ü gelmiş arkadaşlar yani bakın sonunda
ü ekleri var Bunlar ortak ekler
bunlara reddet dedim ve sildim gelene
kaldı söz göz kaldı Bakın arkadaşlar
sözün sondaki Z ile gözün sonundaki Z ve
Özün sonundaki Z ortak Bunu yazdım
özdeki Z'nin yanında ö var yine burada
da ö var burada da var Dolayısıyla
ikinci ses benzerimiz ö arkadaşlar bakın
1 ve 2 tane ses benzerimiz var bu Tam
kafiye olacak dedim ve geldik jimnastik
kahve arkadaşlar az önce Dedim ki
anlamları aynı olan kelimelerin Dize
sonunda tekrar etmesi rediftir ama
anlamları farklı olan ve bununla
birlikte sesleri aynı olan sözcüklerin
tekrar etmesini ise cansız kıyafete
denir Nasıl mı bakalım ne için kondun
abi Bülbül dalındaki asmaya Ben yarından
vazgeçmem götürseler asmaya bakıyoruz
arkadaşlar götürseler asmaya derken
orada asmak fiildir yani idam etmek Ama
ne için kondun abi Bülbül Kapımdaki
asmaya derken oradaki üzüm ağacıdır Üzüm
yaprağıdır bakın asmaya asmaya okunuşlar
aynı ama anlamlar bambaşka Dolayısıyla
bu şekilde bir örnek varsa buna cinas
deriz arkadaşlar ve şimdi Tunç kafiye
bakalım Tunç kafiye ile arkadaşlar dizi
sonunda bir kelimenin diğer bir dize
sonundaki kelime içinde Aynen geçmesiyle
oluşan bir kafeye çeşididir ne demek
istiyorum örneğe Bakalım Uzaktan bir
tren sesi gelince hasretle sızlayan
Kalbimiz ince bakın ince sözcüğü gelince
sözcüğün içerisinde Aynen geçiyor mu
geçiyor arkadaşlar İşte buna da Tunç
kafiye deniliyor Tunç kafiye olabilmesi
için Arkadaşlar en az 3 ses
benzerliğinin olması gerekiyor ama MEB
kitaplarını Tunç kafiye göremezsiniz
Birazcık böyle tartışmalı bir konu çok
kaynak bunu zengin kafi olarak da
değerlendiriyor Bu nedenle MEB kitabında
yok ÖSYM'de bu tür konuları sormaz Bunu
unutma ve şimdi devam edelim ve kafeye
nasıl bulunur soruyorsa Cevap vermek
istiyorum Arkadaşlar bir Öncelikle
unutma kafe her zaman size sonunda
aranır iki Dize sonunda Öncelikle redifi
arayacağız redifi bulduk ya da bulamadık
sonra kafeye geçeceğiz ve 3 hiçbir zaman
unutma kafe genellikle Dize sonundaki
kelimelerin
bu Mantıklı hareket ederseniz işiniz
daha da kolaylaşacaktır mesela
örneğimize
bakalım yazıldı bozuldu paslanmalıdır
birçok konuda söylenmiştir yazılmıştır
işte şiir türleri de bu şiirlerin
konusuna göre
sınıflandırılmasıdır bunu da hızlı bir
şekilde geçmek istiyorum Öncelikle lirik
şiire bakalım arkadaşlar Aşk tabiat
güzellik gibi bakın duygusal konular Bir
şiirde işleniyorsa Biz o şiire lirik
şiir diyoruz Eğer Bir şiirde Savaş varsa
kahramanlık varsa yiğitlik varsa
epopeden gelir Bunu unutma o şiiri Biz
epik deriz didaktik de arkadaşlar
öğretici bilgi verici demektir
Dolayısıyla dedi Artık şiir de bilgi
veren nasihat içeren şiirlerdir pastoral
şiir ise arkadaşlar Doğaç şiiridir Yani
bir köy hayatı Bir çobanın yaşamı
anlatılıyorsa mesela o şiire Biz
pastoral şiir deriz satirik şiir ise
arkadaşlar eleştiri şiiridir bir kişi ya
da bir toplumu eleştiriyorsanız Bu
şiirin adı satirik şiirdir halk
edebiyatında Biz satirik şiire taşlama
deriz divan edebiyatındaki Nazım türü
ise hicviyedir hiçbir yerlerde bir
eleştiri yapılır diyorum ve böylelikle
şiir türlerinde bitirdik şimdi konumuz
İmge Bu da önemli karşımıza sınavlarda
çıkacaktır mutlaka bir soru olarak
gerçekliğin dışında şairlerin Dış Dünya
gözlemlerine yola çıkarak kendi hayal
dünyasında oluşturmuş oldukları
görüntülere Tabi sadece zihin dünyasını
oluşturmayacaklar bunu aynı zamanda
şiiri yansıtacaklar işte arkadaşlar buna
İmge denir Türk Dil Kurumu sözlüğünde de
İmge şöyle açıklanmıştır zihninde
tasarlanan ve gerçekleşmesi Özlenen şey
hayat işte Arkadaşlar bu hayali şiir
yansıtmasına ne diyoruz İmge ediyoruz
binlerce kelime vardır arkadaşlar
dilimizde ancak insanın hayal dünyası o
kadar geniş ki bu hayal dünyasını Bazen
kelimeler anlatmayabilir işte arkadaşlar
o zaman şairde nereye başvurur imgeye
başvurur ve imge şiirin anlam dünyasını
inanılmaz derecede geliştirir ve yine
önemli bir bilgi imgeler Özgün olmak
zorunda yani O hayal gücü sana ait
olacak Daha önce hayal edilen şiire yans
şeyler imgeyi oluşturmaz arkadaşlar
mesela Onu her gördüğümde aklım
kırılıyordu şimdi akıl kırılması diye
bir şey daha önceden Duydunuz mu
duymadınız bu şairin hayal gücü aklın
kırıldığını hayal etmiş Dolayısıyla
Arkadaşlar bu nedir Bu bir imgedir
eğilmiş arıza kanar muttasıl kanar
güller durur alev gibi dallarda kanlı
Bülbüller sular mı yandı neden Tunca
benziyor mermer demiş Ahmet Haşim bakın
Kaan içinde kalmış güller alev gibi
yanan dallardaki o Bülbüller ve suların
yanması Bu tamamen şairin Hayal
dünyasıdır Hayal gücüdür bu hayal
gücünde şiire yazdığı için Buna ne denir
Buna İmge denir arkadaşlar imgede buydu
bakın alışılmışın dışında bir görüntü
varsa şehirde ona direkt İmge
diyebilirsiniz Şimdi geldik edebi
sanatlara edebi sanat nedir anlatımdaki
etkiyi arttırmak anlattığımız
zenginleştirmek güçlendirmek ve
renklendirmek için dilin anlam ve
sembolik gücünü kullanma özelliklerine
analiz edebi sanat diyoruz birçok edebi
sanat var arkadaşlar hiç vakit
kaybetmeden şu edebi sanatlara hızlıca
göz atalım Tabii ki burada hızlı bir
şekilde göz atacağım ama siz daha yavaş
bir anlatım daha detaylı bir anlatım
istiyorsanız onu da videosunu paylaştım
zaten kanalımda mevcut oynatma listesi
var orada Tüm konuları tek tek daha
ayrıntılı bir şekilde anlatıyorum o
videolarımda seyredebilirsiniz ama genel
bir tekrar yapmak için şimdi edebi
sanatları göz atıyoruz Öncelikle teşbih
yani benzetme sanatına bakalım
Arkadaşlar bir şeyi bir şeye
benzetirseniz buna teşbih sanatı denir
mesela Kükremiş sel gibiyim bendimi
çiğner aşarım Bakın arkadaşlar Türk
milletine benzetilmiş kükremiş Bir Sele
benzetilmiş kükremişsel kendisine
benzetilendir gibi benzetme edatıdır Bir
de benzeyen vardır arkadaşlar O da
burada şairin kendisidir Ben aslında
kendisinin üzerinden de Türk milletini
kastetmiştir Ahmet krallar gibi
yaşıyordu bakın Ahmet kime benzetilmiş
Kralı benzetmiş hangi yönüyle benzetmiş
lüks içerisinde yaşaması yönüyle Peki
benzetme edatı nedir gibi yani
arkadaşlar benzetmenin 4 tane ögesi
vardır benzeyen kendisine benzetilen
benzetme yönü ve benzetme edatı Bunlar
da önemli Aklımızdan çıkarmayalım
diyorum ve şimdi geldik teşbih deliğe
yani güzel benzetmeye arkadaşlar öyle
bir benzetme yapacaksınız ki o
benzetmede sadece kendisine benzetilen
ve benzeyen olacak yani benzetme yönüyle
benzetme edatı olmayacak Bu tarzdaki
benzetmeleri teşbih belli denir mesela
Kim bu cennet vatanın uğruna olmaz feda
ederken Vatan burada arkadaşlar
benzeyendir Peki Vatan neye
benzetilmiştir arkadaşlar yani kendisine
benzetilen nedir burada cennettir cennet
gibi güzel Vatan bakın güzel benzetme
yönü gibi benzetme dezatıdır Ama bunlar
kullanılmamış sadece kendisine
benzetilen ve benzeyen varsa buna ne
deniliyordu teşbih beli deniliyordu
diyorum ve şimdi geldik istihareye
arkadaşlar Az önce ne demiştik 4 tane
benzetme unsuru vardı benzeyen kendisine
benzetilen benzetme yönü ve benzetme
edatı benzeyen ve kendisine benzetilen
kullanırsa buna teşvik beli deniliyordu
bunlardan sadece bir tanesini
kullanırsam bu açık istisare ya da
kapalı hisari olur ne demek istiyorum
şimdi örneklere bakalım açık sarı
arkadaşlar sadece benzetmede kendisine
benzetilen varsa yani güçlü olan unsur
varsa buna Biz açık istisar ediyoruz
bakalım aslanlarımız düşmanı denize
döktü aslanlarımız arkadaşlar burada
kendisine benzetilendir peki burada
kastedilen kimdir yani benzeyen kimdir
benzeyen burada arkadaşlar askerlerdir
Peki askerler yani benzer kullanılmış mı
Hayır sadece kendisine benzetilen
kullanıldığı için buna Biz açık istrar
ediyoruz Aynı şekilde Bir Hilal Uğruna
Ya Rab ne güneşler batıyor güneşler
burada şehitlerimize benzetilmiş
güneşler kendisine benzetilen sadece
kendisine benzetilen kullanıldığı için
buna açık istihare ediyoruz bunun tam
tersi yani sadece benzeyen kullanırsa
burada arkadaşlar kapalı istisar edilir
mesela oyuncular sağda adeta kükredi
oyuncular kükremesi ile kime
benzetilmiştir aslana yani Aslan burada
Aslında kendisine benzetilen ama
kullanılmış mı Hayır sadece benzeyen
kullanmış arkadaşlar Dolayısıyla Buna ne
denir kapalı ısrar edilir içinde damla
damla bir korku birikiyor korku su gibi
damlamış suya benzetmiş Peki kendisine
benzetilen yani su kullanılmış mı Hayır
sadece korku var yani benzeyen var
Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar burada ne
olacaktır kapalı Hisarlar olacaktır Bu
kadar basit dedim ve şimdi geliyoruz
mecazi müsele yani at aktarmasına at
aktarması bir şey söylüyorsunuz ama onun
üzerinden başka bir şey kastediyorsunuz
işte arkadaşlar buna mecazi müsellenir
günlük yaşamda bunu sıklıkla kullanırız
mesela uçak İzmir'e inmek üzereydi
İzmir'e iner yoksa İzmir'deki
havaalanına biner Tabii ki arkadaşlar
İzmir'de bulunan Adnan Menderes
havaalanından iner ancak havaalanını
yerine ne demiş İzmir demişim at
aktarması yapmışım
üşüdüğünde sobayı yakarsın ya sobayı
yakarsın yoksa sobanın içerisindeki
kömürleri odunları mı yakarsın Tabii ki
içindekileri yakarsın Ancak bütün
söylenerek içi kastedilmiş işte
Arkadaşlar bir ad aktarması var Recep
fazıl'ı severek okurum Necip Fazıl
okuyamazsınız arkadaşlar onun şiirlerini
okursunuz Dolayısıyla Burada da bir ad
aktarması vardır tüm sınıfı yarın sözlü
yapacağım mekan söylenmiş ama kastedilen
o mekanın içerisindeki öğrencilerdir dış
mekan ama kastedilen içi Dolayısıyla
Burada da bir at aktarması Vardır dedim
ve şimdi geldik teşhis yani kişileştirme
sanatı arkadaşlar insan dışındaki
varlıklara insani özelliklerinin
verilmesine Biz kişileştirme diyoruz bir
yağmur başlar ya inceden inceye Bak o
zaman topraktaki sevinci Toprak insan
gibi sevinmiş şahıslaştırılmış yani
kişileştirilmiş Dolayısıyla burada bir
teşhis sanatı vardır teşhis şhs köküne
dayanır yani şahıs köküne dayanır
şahıslaştırma
bir arada kullanılmış Dolayısıyla
Arkadaşlar bu tenasüp duruyor ya da
burada da örnek verdiğim gibi Okul
öğretmen sınıf öğrenci kalem defter
bakın hepsi birbiriyle ilgili kelimeler
Buna da yine tenasüp denir Şimdi geldik
tezat sanatına Arkadaşlar bir biriyle
zıt olan kavramların kelimelerinin aynı
dizede aynı şehirde kullanılmasına Biz
tezat sanatı diyoruz Neden böyle düşman
görünürsünüz yıllar yılı dost bildiğim
aynalar bakın dost ve düşman zıt değil
mi zıt kullanılmışsa orada bir tezat
sanatı vardır şimdi Termin sanatına
gelelim yani hatırlatma sanatı öncesinde
yaşanmış bir olayı tarihi bir kişiliği
durumu atasözünü hatırlatırsan
arkadaşlar buna telmih sanatı denir
bakıyoruz gönlünün şerrinin aşkı Sarınca
o hızla dağları ferhatınca Ne yapmışız
Şirin'le Ferhat hikayesini atıpta
bulmuşuz o hikayeyi hatırlatmışız
Dolayısıyla ne vardır burada telmih
sanatı vardır bir de Hüsnü talil sanatı
arkadaşlar hüs güzellik demektir talil
sebeptir Dolayısıyla şöyle çevirebiliriz
güzel nedene bağlama sanatı bir şeyin
sebebini başka bir duruma ki bu durum
genellikle daha güzel bir durum olur
Bunu Arkadaşlar biz Hüsnü Tali sanatı
diyoruz mesela Haziranda Kiraz Dalı
çocuklar uzansın diye yere doğru eğilir
Ya Kiraz Dalı Sizce bunun için eğilir
Hayır meyve verir ağırlaşır ondan dolayı
eğilebilir ancak ne yapmış burada Şair
ya da sanatçı vesaire kimse bir güzel
nedene bağlama yapmış Dolayısıyla buna
Hüsnü tarihli denir güzel şeyler
düşünelim diye yemyeşil oluvermiş
ağaçlar ya ağaçlar Sizce Biz güzel
şeyler düşünelim diye mi yemyeşil olmuş
Hayır arkadaşlar Hiç alakası yok Ancak
Burada bir güzel nedene bağlama yapılmış
yani üstünü talil sanatı ve geliyoruz
tecavüze ayrı sanatı Yani bilipte
bilinemezlikten gelme şu örneğe bakalım
şakaklarıma kar mı yağdı Ne var benim mi
Allah'ım bu çizgili yüzsüz ya
şakaklarıma Kar mı Yağmış diyor şayet
Sizce saçlarının beyazladığını bilmiyor
mu biliyor ama ne yapıyor bilmezlikten
geliyor arkadaşlar yine benim mi alan Bu
çizgi yüz derken aynaya baksam bu yüzün
benim olup olmadığı Sizce Benim
tarafımdan bilinmiyor mu Tabii ki
biliniyor ama bilmemezlikten geliyorum
Dolayısıyla ticari Arif sanatı yapıyorum
ve geliyoruz kinaye Arkadaşlar bu önemli
bakın kinayı Sakın ha tarih sanatıyla
karıştırmayın kinayet şudur bir sözün
hem gerçek hem de mecaz anlama gelecek
şekilde kullanılmasına Biz kinay sanat
deriz mesela işleyen demir pas tutmaz
ateş düştüğü yeri yakar ya gerçekten
ateş düştüğü yeri yakar mı Evet ateş
düştüğü yeri yakar bu gerçek anlamdır
ama aynı zamanda Biz bunu mecaz anlamda
bir deyim olarak da kullanırız birinin
başına kötü bir şey gelir üzülürüz
cenazesine gideriz Allah korusun Ama
sonra iki gün sonra bunu unuturuz ama o
kişi bu acıyı yaşamaya devam eder Biz de
ne deriz maalesef işte ateş düştüğü yeri
yakıyor Biz unuttuk ama o acıyı yaşamaya
devam edecek ne Arkadaşlar bu sözü mecaz
anlamda kullandık yine aynı şekilde
işleyen demir pas tutmaz gerçekten bir
demir işliyorsa pas tutmaz ancak bir
demiri Atıl bir durumda kenarda
bırakırsanız paslanır bu gerçek anlamda
Ama bir de biz bunu mecaz anlamda
kullanırız mesela sürekli çalışan Emek
harcayan bir hareket olan kişi için
deriz ki ya işleyen demir işte pas
tutmuyor Bu da mecaz anlamda bakın hem
mecaz anlam hem gerçek anlam Neymiş bu
kinay yemiş Peki tariz ne tariz iğneleme
sanatı Yani laf sokma sanatı arkadaşlar
mesela bakıyoruz adamınız gerçekten
ustaymış Ha onun eli değeri bizim makine
kararsızdı bıraktı artık hiç çalışmıyor
ne yaptım güzel bir laf söyledim bu
tarih sanattır ya da ne kadar kültürlü
olduğu yazılarından belli ya buraya da
bilmem koyarak zaten böyle olmadığını
aslında laf soktuğumu ifade ediyorum
Bunu arkadaşlar Hayret şanslısın denir
dedim ve gelelim İrsali mesel sanatına
şiir de atasözü ya da bir özdeyiş
kullanmaz sanatına Biz bir sayının
mesela sanat diyoruz balık kokar bunu
bilmemek Seyrani gafilin ahmaklığından
ya Balık baştan kokar şeklinde bir deyim
var bunu şiirde kullanmışsan buna ne
santlenir İrsali mesel sanatı denir ve
son olarak geldik arkadaşlar mübalağa
yani abartma sanatı bakın örneği ne
kadar abarttığımı göreceksiniz Manda
Yuva Yapmış Söğüt Dalına Yavrusunu sinek
kapmış ya manda gibi kocaman bir hayvan
ince dalları olan Söğüt Ağacına yuva
yapabilir mi yapamaz bir abartı ya da
Mandanın Yavrusunu sinek kapabilir mi ya
ne kadar büyük bir abartı var görüyor
musunuz işte arkadaşlar buna Biz mübala
sanatı diyoruz ve böylelikle Edebi
sanatlarda bitirdik arkadaşlar ancak
tekrar belirtmek istiyorum ki edebi
sanatlarla ilgili Ben kanalımda ayrıca
video paylaştım orada daha yavaş daha
fazla ayrıntıya değindim o videoyu da
seyredebilirsiniz ama genel anlamda
hızlı bir şekilde tekrar yapmak adına bu
video Gerçekten güzel oldu dedim ve
şimdi geldik Arkadaşlar bu ünitenin dil
bilgisi konusu olan sıfatlara sıfat
nedir hemen tar bakalım isimlerden önce
gelerek onları sayı renk durum hareket
biçim yer işaret ve soru yönlerinden
tamamlayan onların niteleyen ya da
belirten kelime ya da kelime gruplarına
bir sıfatıyoruz yani arkadaşlar
isimlerin önüne gelerek onların
niteleyen ya da belirten sözcüklere
kısaca sıfat denir Bu kadar basit
sıfatlar genellikle isimlerden önce
gelir Bakın bu önemli sıfatlar çekim
eklerini alamazlar burada örnek vermişim
güzel araba demişim güzel Onu belirten
niteleyen bir sıfat Peki güzeller Dersem
ne olur sıfat özelliğini kaybeder yani
çekim eki almaz sıfatlar ve sıfatlar tek
başlarına kullanılmaz güzel araba derken
Evet güzel orada sıfattır Peki sadece
güzel Dersem ne olur isimleşir
arkadaşlar Neden Çünkü önde ismim yok ki
ismi belirtilsin onun özelliğini
göstersin ya da mavi kalem diyorum ya
mavi dersem bakın Mavi Mavi ne Neyi
göstereyim Neyi belirtiyor belli değil
Dolayısıyla sıfatlar isimlerden önce
gelmeli tek başlarına olmamalı tamam mı
bu bilgileri de öğrendiysek şimdi devam
edelim sıfatları arkadaşlar Arkadaşlar
biz kendi içerisinde niteleme ve
belirtme sıfatları olarak ikiye ayırırız
ama belirtme sıfatları da kendi
içerisinde işaret sayı belgisiz ve soru
sıfatı olmak üzere 4'e ayrılır hiç vakit
kaybetmeden Niteleme sıfatlarına bakalım
Nitelik nedir Arkadaşlar nitelik
özelliktir Yani bir ismin özelliğini
gösteren ve nasıl sorusuna cevap veren
sıfatlar bize mesaj sıfatıdır kalem
nasıl kalem kırmızı bakın onun
özelliğini gösteriyor Silgi nasıl silgi
yuvarlak silgi çocuk nasıl çocuk küçük
çocuk yaramaz çocuk çekilmez çocuk nasıl
tahta akıllı tahta bakın her ismin
özelliğini gösteren bu sözcükler ne
olacaktır sıfat olacaktır çeşit olarak
da Niteleme sıfatı belirtme sıfatı ise
onları gösterme belirsizlik sayı ve soru
yoluyla belirten sıfatlardır belirtme
sıfatları dörde ayrılır demiştim Şimdi
arkadaşlar sayı sıfatıyla devam edelim
sayı sıfatlarını görelim sayısı
sıfatlarında maalesef kendi içerisinde
dörde ayrılıyor Ama iyi haber kolay
bakalım arkadaşlar öncelikle asıl ses
patladı
serisinden önce gelerek o ismin sayısını
gösteren sıfatlara Biz Asıl sayı sıfatı
diyoruz ve kaç sorusuna cevap veriyor
kaç saat sonra gelecek sordum 3 cevabını
aldım 3 nedir burada Asıl sayı sıfatıdır
devam ediyoruz sıra sayı sıfatlarına
geldik bu da arkadaşlar o ismin sırasını
gösteren sıfatlardır kaçıncı sorusuna
cevap verir kaçıncı sayfası 5 sayfası
bakın cevabı bulduk Dolayısıyla 5 nedir
sıra sayısıdır bir diğeri de üleştirme
sıfatı varlıkların ayrıldığı eşit
bölümleri gösteren sıfatlardır Bu da
kaçar sorusuna cevap verir kaçar soru
çıkacakmış 6'şar soru çıkacakmış Bakın
arkadaşlar birleştirme yani paylaştırma
var burada da Dolayısıyla Buna da
üleştirme sıfatı denir ve şimdi geldik
kesir sayı sıfatına Arkadaşlar bu da bir
ismin belli bir oranını gösteren
sıfatlardır mesela başarı Peki kaç
Başarı yüzde yetmiş bakın %100 bir
bütündür onun sadece yüzde yetmişini
ifade ettiği için bu kesir sayı
sıfatıdır ya da çeyrek altın yarım ekmek
Bunlar da kesir sayı sıfatıdır dedim ve
geldik işaret sıfatı varlıkların ve
nesnelerin yerlerini işaret yoluyla
gösteren sıfatlara Biz işaret sıfatı
deriz en çok kullanılan işaret sıfatı bu
şu odur arkadaşlar Onun dışında böyle
öyle şöyle öteki beriki öte beri diğer
İşte bunlar da isimlerden önce gelirse
Buna da işaret sıfatı denir hangi
sorusuna da cevap verebilir mesela
Bakalım bu masanın yerini değiştirelim
masa burada nedir arkadaşlar Masa burada
isimdi Peki hangi masa soruyoruz bu
cevabını alıyoruz bakın işaret yoluyla
gösteriyorum Bu masa şu değil o bu bu bu
Bunu kaldır diyor bakın ne yaptım işaret
etti Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar işaret
sıfatıdır ama ne dedim sıfatlar
yakalamaz Mesela şöyle desem bunun
yerini değiştirin bunun Dediğim an ne
oluyor öndeki isim kalkıyor Dolayısıyla
bu sıfat özelliğini kaybediyor devam
edelim öteki çocuğu hangi çocuk öteki
çocuk şu çocuk değil bakın işaret
ediyorum Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar öteki
burada işaret sıfatıdır eve hırsız
girmiş Hangi gibi
ve yine işaret yoluyla gösterdiği için
bu da işaret sıfatı olacaktır Ve geldik
belgesi sıfatlar bunu da dikkatli bir
şekilde dinle varlıkları kavramları
Onlara kesinlikle kazandırmadan Yani
aşağı yukarı olacak şekilde gösteren
sıfatları da biz belgisiz sıfatı birkaç
çok bir çok bazı tüm her bütün hiçbir
herhangi kimi bir takım gibi sözcükleri
Siz ismin önüne getirirseniz Bunlar
belki sıfatlar olur mesela örneklere
Bakalım tüm öğrenciler karnesini aldı
öğrenciler Bu arada isimdir hangi
öğrenciler tüm şimdi tüm öğrenciler
derken bu öğrenci arkadaşlar 5 mi 10 mu
50 mi Ahmet mi Mehmet mahşemi Hayır bir
belirsizlik var Tamam gösteriyorsun ama
belli belirsiz gösterdiğin için bu tüm
buralarda arkadaşlar ne olacaktır
belgesiz sıfat olacaktır insanlar hangi
insanlar Bazı insanlar bakın insanları
gösteriyor ama kaç insan Hangi insan
Belli mi değil bir belirsizlik var
Dolayısıyla bazı burada belgisiz
sıfattır soru kaç soru Hangi soru birçok
soru bakın gösteriyor belirtiyor ama
belirsizlik var Birçok doğru derken 5
tane mi 10 tane 20 tane mi Hayır belli
değil Dolayısıyla Arkadaşlar bu nedir bu
belgisiz sıfattır diyorum ve şimdi
geldik Soru sıfatlarına isimleri soru
yoluyla belirten sıfatlardır Az önce
sıfatları bulmak için hangi soruları
kullandık hangi yıl kullandık kaç
kaçıncı kaçar ne kadar işte Arkadaşlar
bu soruları Siz isimlerin öncesine
getirirseniz orada bir soru sıfatı
yapmış olursunuz bakalım hangi arabayı
aldın araba burada isimdir arkadaşlar
Peki bu ismi bir soru yoluyla gösteren
sözcük nedir Hangi nedir Arkadaşlar
hangi arabayı aldın ismin önünde
Dolayısıyla Bu hangi burada soru sıfatı
olacak cevap verelim diyelim ki
Arkadaşlar şu arabayı aldım şu arabayı
derken şu ne olur burada işaret sıfatı
olur işareti sıfatını bulmak için hangi
soruyu kullanıyorduk hangi yıl
kullanıyorduk işte arkadaşlar Aslında
soru sıfatlarının Cevabı da ilgili sıfat
olmakta Neyse devam edelim kaçıncı
bölümü bitirdi bölüm burada isimdir yaz
bakalım diyelim ki 5 bölümü bitirdim
Bakın arkadaşlar bölüm burada isim 5
isim burada sıra sayı sıfatıdır sıra
sayısı sıfatınmak için hangi soruyu
kullanıyorduk kaçıncı sorusunu
kullanıyorduk kaçıncı sorusunda Siz
ismin önüne getirirseniz ne oluyormuş
soru sıfatı oluyormuş bu işten kaçar
lira kazandınız diyelim ki Beşer lira
Beşer lira derken bu nedir bu üleştirme
sıfatıdır arkadaşlar birleşme sıfatını
bulmak için hangi soruyu kullanıyorduk
kaçar sorusunu kullanıyorduk ve bunu da
ismin önüne getirirsen ne oluyormuş soru
sıfatı oluyormuş Anlaştık mı
anlaştığımızı düşünüyorum ve son olarak
geldik antlaşma Bazen arkadaşlar
niteleme sıfatları bakın baskı
sıfatlarda değil niteleme sıfatları
çekim eki alırlarsa önündeki isimleri
düşürürler ve bu şekilde arkadaşlar o
ismin de özelliğini üstüne alırlar İşte
buna adlaşmış sıfat diyoruz arkadaşlar
nasıl mı bakalım Yaşlı insanlar çok
duygusal olur yerine şöyle dersem
arkadaşlar yaşlı çok duygusal olur ne
olur arkadaşlar Şuradaki lar 2 Şuradaki
insanlar sözcüğünün yerine geçti
yaşlılar diyorum Normalde yaşlı sıfattı
ancak yaşlar derken öndeki isim düştü
yaşlılar aynı zamanda insanları da
karşılar duruma geldi işte Arkadaşlar
bunu adlaşmış sıfat denir Çalışkan
öğrenciler demek yerine desem ki
Çalışkanlar kütüphaneden çıkmıyor bakın
Ne oldu öğrenciler düştü buradaki
Çalışkanlar öğrenci karşılar duruma
geldi İşte buna adlaşmış sıfat diyoruz
ama tekrar belirtmek istiyorum ki bu
Niteleme sıfatına özel bir durumdur
başkası sıfatlarda olmaz ve böylelikle
bu videomuzun da sonuna geldik
arkadaşlar çok konuştum Çok Yoruldum
Terledim umarım bunun karşılığı gelir
karşılığı ne karşılığı sizlerin bu
videoyu beğenmesi ve faydalı bulması
yani derslerinize sınavlarınızda bu
video Ufak da olsa bir katkıda
bulunuyorsa işte Arkadaşlar bu iş
olmuştur terlememe değmiştir Ben
beğendim Gerçekten faydalı olacaktır
sınavlar öncesinde seyrediyorsan bu
videoyu mükemmel bir çalışma olur tekrar
amaçlı seyrediyorsan da bilgiler
zihninde daha da pekişecektir bunu net
bir şekilde söyleyebilirim ben yoruldum
ama Eminim buna değecek bir video ortaya
çıktı Umarım Sizlerde aynı şeyi
düşünüyorsunuzdur Eğer videomuzu
Beğendiyseniz lütfen kanalımıza abone
olmayı bu videoyu beğenmeyi ve
arkadaşlarınızla paylaşmayı unutmayın
her türlü olumlu olumsuz düşüncenizde
yorum olarak lütfen benimle paylaşın
bitti mi Hayır Arkadaşlar aynı zamanda
bu ünite ile ilgili bir PDF çalışma
kağıdı hazırladım Mutlaka onu da indirin
ve arkadaşlarınızla paylaşın bu PDF
çalışma kağıdı da büyük bir katkı
sunacak sizlere Öyleyse Bir sonraki
derste bir sonraki videoda tekrar
görüşürüz kendinize iyi bakın hoşça
kalın Sevgiyle kalın